we are here with Russell Bobbitt how are
you are you guys are gonna see more
marbles eat the universe soon but we
have our marvelous prop master here and
we have a amazing man who's this Oh have
you heard of Robert Downey jr. yeah yes
yes Helmuth from Iron Man 1 so this he
this this is the real one
you're a little tongue-tied that's the
actual helmet that we use to in Ironman
one in the cave scene after he built it
to break out of the cave well I mean it
is so cool I would like to know how you
built it because he you're the man with
the plan that made this all come
together right yeah well this one we
originally we pounded metal and he was
in the cave doing mental and so we
thought about offering him up a steel
helmet which ended up at about 45 pounds
helmet yeah not cool when were they
where where they were shot at Sony on
stage and what was awesome about it is
that we
to feel cold in the in the cave and they
wanted the breath to show so they
refrigerated the set down to 32 degrees
and we shot in there for several weeks
and with parkas and like the crew was
just freezing and miserable but it
turned out great and he had to wear like
a tank top yeah and so imagine that
crazy anyway this is fiberglass resin
there's a cap under underneath so he can
wear it comfortably so on oh I honestly
thought it was just a light or like a
light in weight metal this paint is
insane this is like I don't want to talk
about money but it's the most expensive
paint on the market to get that metallic
look I mean it's so it's so realistic
but this is also the mark one helmet is
going to be part of the marbled
masterworks collection it is yeah so so
Kevin Feige and and Disney and Marvel
wanted to offer the serious collector a
way to purchase stuff that we make on
set and there's lots of great products
out there and great licensees that do
wonderful replicas and but this is
coming straight out of our camp so
they've asked me to take my original
molds my craftsmen and make a limited
edition of 50 to 250 extra pieces so
it's additional parts from the same
exact mold so it's about as authentic
authentic as it's going to get and and
here we are - to launch that today and
and it's going to be the Iron Man helmet
it's Groot it's a cap shield with the
Panther claws it's this helmet and it's
a dr. Strange's eye of agamotto the
great part of the aya
- it's the first one that you that
anyone has seen in public and it's on
display here today because it's got the
from the same mold from the same sculpt
the time stone from the Infinity
Gauntlet in infinity war it's
one-of-a-kind at the moment yeah so it's
pretty I'm excited about it yeah it was
my - just reading a little bit about the
eye of agamotto bed it's all like you
have special leather artisans that
create that that the lanyard piece yeah
yeah just to hold it around your neck is
a 10-hour build and literally it's it's
strips of leather leather woven and tied
to you know specific colors to make sure
that it all matches what's unique about
all this stuff is that really if you
look at it they're all a one-of-a-kind
because they're handmade but it's my job
to make sure everything matches and
that's because I have to use multiples
on set if one breaks we got to throw
another one in so it's really difficult
to try to make everything match and make
it look right but that's what we do and
so so well it seems like they're
duplicates they're really one-of-a-kind
pieces because paint jobs and leather
work and and black panther claws are all
hand done yeah and they're super limited
I the chavo ring to chop this ring is so
cool I I think the first thing I thought
was oh I hope someone gets married and
uses that as their wedding band
it's gorgeous piece and - like I'm nice
around my so I can't do all this by
myself so I surround myself with really
talented people that that are artisans
and manufacturers and in this particular
case with the ring I wanted to offer a
real piece of jewelry so I didn't make
it like I made a prop I called this dear
friend of mine who's a jeweler got
together with him partnered up and he's
making the jewelry for us so it's it's a
sterling silver ring played it in white
and black rhodium and it's the real deal
now what's interesting about that is
when you order it you get a size 11 and
that's all you get because I'm keeping
it true to the movie prop so you're
getting chadwick boseman ring size and
that's what you get yeah that's cool
like authenticity is if you're buying
these that's what's important yeah it
was important to us because I'm not
making replicas I'm making additional
pieces and for that reason I can't
change a thing on it and nor would I
want to
I think the little Groot it's so
interesting how was that used in filming
right so uh so I puppeteer rocket and
Groot
on set which is almost like one of the
wildest jobs that I have in my
repertoire but I'm out there holding
Groot and acting out the scenes so that
the actors have their eye lines and they
know where to look and when so I'm out
there now with root it's great because
the dialogue is pretty easy yeah but but
if screwed starts on a sofa and jumps
onto a table I have to give them that
eyeline and we roll cameras on one take
doing that and then they you know all
their everybody the crew the ADEs they
all waved me out of there and then the
actors do the scene
again for real and so I'm gluten rockin
off-camera I share that stage with
Bradley Cooper and bindi I'm there to
fill in momentarily he wear many hats in
January I went to your workshop and got
to see a lot of this stuff and I
remember holding the the actual Groot
and looking at the one that's down there
it is it's exactly the same yeah yeah
well there I'll tell you a little secret
what I did but between then and now I
watched the movie and I got the 3d files
from the the post-production folks and I
embellished crude a little bit to make
him look more like the one in the film
because it made me feel better and and
you know it was it was sort of you know
when I was when I'm puppeteering him I
wanted him to have the the actual feel
in the look and also it helps the
lighting guys and the 3d modelers on set
because they see how you know light is
going to hit hit the what I call the
actor and so so we made him pretty true
to what what is in the final film
it's so awesome you know the thing I
love too about the way you create props
is that they tell such a big part of the
story and especially with cap shield you
know you see the vibranium versus
vibranium it's the only thing that can
scratch caps shield how do you look at
props in that way to tell the story
well it's interesting I people often ask
me what my favorite prop is well I treat
the props like children they're they're
a concept at first and then and then we
illustrate and we we go into like you
know the planning mode how are we going
to raise this prop from from conception
to finish product and we sort of massage
it and we go through many drawings we
get approvals from the director and then
I speak to the actors and we deal with
scale how big how small it should be and
and then we go to the manufacturing
process and that prop is born and and I
then look at it and I'm like well a
little too big let's make it bigger
let's make a smaller let's say and
whatever I have to do to make it work
until the finished product happens and
then I let it go off to college I let it
go I put it out on the set we maintain
it if it breaks we fix it something
wrong especially I get their call for
money we also you know we saw these
things down there and you're you're
actually at comic-con here talking to
the fans who are walking by what are the
questions that they're asking you about
these items I get so many questions some
appropriate and some not most people
just ask me if they can take them home
with them all these props no I'm out
meet and greeting with the people
because they're so used to coming to
comic-con and seeing really cool stuff
in a display and they take a picture and
they go home and that's what they get I
don't think people are really
understanding and realizing that we're
offering a limited edition out there for
people and so I'm out there meet and
greeting telling them Who I am
and saying you two can have one of these
props now coming straight out of my camp
and and it's important for us to offer
that and it's the first time and it's in
honor of the ten year anniversary that
they felt this was a great time to do it
and so I'm gonna but I am asked all
kinds of crazy questions some that I
wouldn't even broadcast here today but
but for the most part people are in awe
that the prop master is actually out
there to meet Magritte and and I love
that I love giving back and sharing with
the people so it's great yeah and it's a
rarity for you to not be completely
heads down on numerous projects I mean
not last I we saw you in January it was
you're like quick breath getting ready
for the next production doing all your
stuff and you were like before we finish
I remember you pulled out a drawer
you're like can we talk about this and
it was an item from a movie from a movie
we hadn't shown yet you're like no no it
was great it was awesome yeah yeah it's
it's hard because I think everyone knows
we shot two Avengers movies concurrent
and so on a 200 day shoot let's say it
gets very confusing for me and others to
think about what we can talk about and
what we can't talk about and we all know
that you know keeping it as you know
keeping the spoilers out of the the mix
is a great thing because even me I love
going to the movie that I worked on and
seeing how it got cut and edited and
what like what it ended up in in
infinity war and what I can anticipate
for the next film and so and by the way
tomorrow I get on a plane and hit the
road running and
we're gonna go lock up that next film
for everybody so you you've also you had
a great panel already are you doing
something here at the booth this weekend
as well yeah yeah so part of the Marvel
master works collection I'm doing an
unboxing the packaging that this stuff
comes in is truly amazing I created a
Stark Industries experience so it comes
in a Stark Industries case you open it
up there's lots of fun little secret
cool things that I'm about to unveil
downstairs that come with this product
and literally my goal was to make every
bit of this experience collectible
you're not going to want to throw away
the cardboard box it comes in so it's
pretty cool and and you know it's out of
my wheelhouse but I embraced it for
Disney Marvel Kevin Feige and the true
honest collector so check it out I do
want to get to a fan question because we
have a bunch sitting here yeah um
someone would like to know if you've
kept any props for yourself and if so
win and will you get in trouble no no
there's some props that you know that
lie around in my shop but under contract
Marvel owns everything just so you know
but but but because I've been with them
for so long I have access to all the
props like we have a huge warehouse we
have a hundred and forty cap shield
sitting around because the life
expectancy of a cap shield is only three
scenes before it's damaged beyond repair
and then we make more so so we have
access to all this stuff but I don't
really like in the first five years of
my my career which was over 30 years ago
I would keep some props and I'd hang
them up on the wall but things kind of
got cluttered after 30
two years a lot of props went through my
my house and so now I just have a proper
house where I don't keep any props but I
have a huge warehouse full of everything
so it's kind of cool and if I'm allowed
one more what has been the hardest
problem for you to find or assemble I am
to say that I don't want to use the word
hard but the most challenging prob was
probably the arc reactor originally in
figuring that out so we thought we'd
open to a bunch of research about
nuclear power and cold fusion and how do
we create an electromagnet that will
keep trap kn'l from your heart because
we know that the shrapnel was barbed
from the Stark Industries bomb and every
breath you take the shrapnel goes closer
and closer to your heart and we had to
create something that would do that now
the big challenge was it's supposed to
look like it's four inches into his
chest right and so I used a lot of force
perspective work so I started with a big
ring and go to a smaller and smaller and
smaller and smaller ring which to the
eye gives you the illusion that it's
deeper and deeper
I think that's an old trick like from
the Alfred Hitchcock days where they
would have long hallways that come down
to nothing so that it would look longer
and they were shooting onstage so I sort
of look at all that I looked at like
film your sort of attitude mixed with a
hi-tech attitude and we came up with the
arc reactor and it's just like such an
iconic cool thing that I'd have to say
that's close to my heart Russell you
know I adore you I adore talking with
you a little tease some point we're
gonna have a long-form interview you and
I we talked a lot about your career
that's gonna be on this weekend Marvel
but here I just say thanks for coming up
thank you giving this to me thank you
Robert for giving me this helmet a
really appreciate
you guys I mean I I wouldn't do this
without you so I'm big fans of yours
honestly and thanks for having me